Okay. Let's follow up to yesterday's story
about democratic fundraising for 2020. Yesterday.
I told you Bernie Sanders had explosive fourth
quarter fundraising in 2019 Bernie raising
34 and a half million dollars.
This was the largest single corridor for any
democratic candidate in the entire 2020 election
cycle. Elizabeth Warren's fundraising was
down Bernie way up. These are very serious
fundraising numbers and these numbers in part
are making the establishment realize along
with the polling that we're seeing over the
last few weeks. As I told you yesterday, Bernie
can win the democratic nomination, whether
he will is a different question, but he is
a serious contender for the democratic nomination.
Fine. I did mention yesterday that Donald
Trump's fundraising still greatly exceeded
that of Bernie Sanders. So let's talk about
those numbers. Despite Bernie's record, 34
and a half million dollars raised last quarter,
Donald Trump raised even more. Donald Trump
raised $46 million in the fourth quarter of
2019 that's about a third more than Bernie.
That's a major advantage for Trump in the
immediate. Now this doesn't include RNC money,
Republican national committee money that will
no doubt pour in for Donald Trump.
Trump now has incredible hundred and $2 million
on hand. Trump has been raising a lot of money.
He's not yet been spending that much since
Democrats are spending money. They raise against
each other because they're in a primary right
now. Donald Trump, at least for now, has no
primary. So the question now becomes, what
does Donald Trump's serious fundraising tell
us? And what I mean by that is if Donald Trump
is mostly raising money from people who voted
for him in 2016 anyway, the fundraising may
or may not tell us very much about how people
are going to vote in November of 2020 if Bernie
Sanders is building a coalition that includes
people who never voted in 2016 it includes
people who were too young to vote in 2016
but now will be voting in 2020 if it includes
people who voted for somebody else in 2016
the change in Bernie's fundraising from 2016
to 2020 might signal significant enthusiasm
from some of the same people who did not support
Bernie in 2016 that would be a good sign for
someone like Bernie Sanders.
There's another question about this though,
which is that Donald Trump raised way more
than any individual democratic candidate in
the fourth quarter of 2019 but Donald Trump
raised way less than all of the democratic
candidates together because Bernie Sanders
raised 34 million and Elizabeth Warren probably
raised close to 20 and Andrew Yang raised
a bunch. And Pete Buddha, judge, right? If
you add it all together, all of the Democrats
together raised significantly more than Donald
Trump. It's not crazy to imagine that as the
democratic primary candidates get whittled
down and eventually we have a nominee that
all of this money will consolidate around
the democratic nominee, and it very well could
exceed the amount of money that Donald Trump
raises. This is all speculative and as, as
a reminder, I know that for a lot of you,
I don't have to do this. We're talking about
this because this is the way the system works.
It's a sick, corrosive, broken system. So
campaign finance needs to be fixed. Money
in politics needs to be fixed. I'm disgusted
by the fact that you have to raise money in
order to have a successful campaign given
that you do. We're talking about it because
we've got an election in 10 months, and right
now the way to win it is you've got to raise
the money, but it's a disgusting system that
we have. Just putting that on record once
again. Um, let's look at the other side of
this. It is possible that Donald Trump's big
fundraising numbers in the last quarter of
2019 do mean that Donald Trump is going to
do very well in 2020. You know, uh, when we
look at the national polling and it says hypothetically,
if it was Biden versus Trump, who would you
vote for? And Biden's winning by nine. Uh,
if it was Biden, if it was a Trump versus
Bernie, who would you vote for?
And Bernie's winning by eight and Warren's
winning by seven. When we look at that, we
might incorrectly think, we've got this, we've
got this in the bag. Especially now with war,
with Iran on the table. It will be an even
bigger challenge. Since presidents often benefit
from military conflict as a way to justify
their own reelection. Donald Trump is raising
a lot of money, so all we can do is fight
for every vote, assumed nothing. Volunteer
phone bank for the eventual democratic nominee.
Get people registered to vote. Remember the
effort that's required to convert one Trumpist.
You can probably get 10 people, maybe even
15 people who already agree with us, but who
aren't thinking about voting. Just convince
them to vote. It's a much more efficient means
of winning the election than trying to argue
with Trump as to or in many cases, completely
beyond reach.
That's my sense of what we need to do over
the next 10 months and it's only 10 months.
Uh, we have, you know, it feels like this
is in a sense just ramping up. We've had a
few debates, but the first votes are going
to be cast. I think it's one month from today.
Uh, we are going to know the nominee certainly
within six months because that's when the
DNC is. I think within three months we will
basically know who the nominee is going to
be. There is not very much time left. The
election is now, Trump is ramping up with
Iran. This is the time to activate and um,
I I actually a a Pat on today's bonus show
is going to bring us some interesting Joe
Biden related stuff that I think will be interesting
to put it lightly and concerning to many in
our audience about some things that Joe Biden
has recently said.
We've got a great bonus show for you today,
producer Pat has the Friday bonus show. I
will be back with a new show and I will be
hosting a bonus show on Monday. Thanks again
for joining me. It is 2020. Keep those suggestions
rolling in about what you want to see more
of from the David Pakman show in 2020. What
do you want to see less of? Some people thought
I was serious yesterday when I said, if you
don't want me hosting the David Pakman show
any more, let me know. That was a joke. I
think I got six or seven real emails from
people saying, David, don't, uh, don't actually,
uh, quit hosting the David Pakman show. I'm
not going to, I'm, that was a joke, but I
do want to hear from you. What do you want
in 2020 a bonus show coming up? You show you
bonus show on Monday, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.
[inaudible].